my name is Diana
Iseman with iseman law firm in Los
Angeles California I'm a criminal
defense attorney and a former prosecutor
today we're going to be watching clips
of various classic movies and looking
into whether or not the characters that
we know and love were actually
committing various forms of sexual
assault I'd like to think you're not in
all of this caper skip it I'm not
interested let's go what would it take
for you to see things my way a lot more
than you've got how do you know I don't
want to know isn't it customary to grant
a condemned man his last request you've
asked for this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god so many crimes let's start
with the first one shall we
battery throws her across the room into
a pile of hay
she tries several times to move her face
so that he can't kiss her and he does
anyway so that's sexual battery in
addition to the battery charge he could
be looking at potential lifetime sex
offender registration because sexual
battery even though it is a misdemeanor
is still a registerable offense now
we're going to watch a scene from
Revenge of the Nerds hi Betty a nerd I'm
not kissing a nerd you have to I paid my
money kiss this nerd I wanted to it all
this kissing's made me horny Betty
you're like a goat
[Music]
next
[Music]
and changed your mind take off your mask
it was wonderful he did things we've
never done before you're that nerd yeah
thanks okay so that was awful and
disturbing to watch because this young
lady was raped the law protects victims
from having sex with someone who is
pretending to be someone else in other
words if she thought she was having sex
with her boyfriend and this guy comes in
wearing a mask
she even asks him she says changed your
mind he says yes they're now going to
have this consensual sex except it isn't
consensual sex it's clearly rape as good
as you yes I think the thing that really
kind of irritates me is that immediately
afterwards when he reveals his identity
she's so okay with it it's totally fine
that she was conned into having sex with
this complete stranger under false
pretenses under most circumstances a
victim like this would go and report it
as a rape they [ __ ] forgot my
birthday the next clip we're gonna watch
is from sixteen Candles a classic John
Hughes coming-of-age story I loved loved
loved John Hughes movies they were the
voice of a generation it's really stupid
he doesn't really exist he asked me
about you did not I go for it in the
best thing is I made a bet with my
friends I bet them that I do with you
but this is before I knew as a person I
can get proof without actually getting
physical how can I borrow your
underpants for 10 minutes I think it's
time to blow this thing off and go to
your house
[Music]
you guys I'm serious come on dude piece
of ass any time I want xiaolin the
bedroom right now passed out cold
violate her ten different ways don't
want to that's disgusting
and it's rape if you did actually go in
and do that make a deal with you
let me keep these unless you take Carol
at home but you got to make sure she
gets home you can't leave in some
parking lot somewhere Jake I'm only
freshmen so she's so Blitz you will know
the difference who's he
that's me what happened I'll tell you
where you are just tell me who you are
did we yeah I'm pretty sure I did I
enjoy it did you you know I have this
weird feeling I did I'm really sorry
about getting you mixed up with that guy
oh it's okay I'm really sorry about last
night
the party oh come on make no qualms
about it she was a rape victim and it
was all orchestrated by someone that she
trusted her boyfriend more than 60% of
sexual assault cases go unreported so I
don't know what she would do but
hopefully she would go to the police and
she would make a report and that
investigation would probably uncover the
fact that this rapist took her in a car
while he was drinking so there's plenty
of underage drunk driving happening here
too she was also violated by many
witnesses that's something that would
play out really unfavorably for the
rapist in the courtroom today so the
next one we're gonna watch his wedding
crashers which is a movie that I
actually laughed out loud almost from
beginning to end when I saw it in the
theater
is going on baby I started thinking
about what you said before and I think
the problem is I am NOT being
adventurous enough for you I'm pretty
sure that is not what I've been saying
to you baby I'm gonna make oh yeah but
this is not men can be victims of sexual
assault too
and in this circumstance I'm pretty sure
that's exactly what happened
they don't make it clear what happens
next it cuts to the next scene pretty
quickly but you're supposed to
understand that they go on to have some
sort of sexual adventure against his
will
seemingly so that is a crime depending
on whether or not there was intercourse
but that would determine what kind of
crime it was but at the very least it is
false imprisonment sexual assaults
definitely
I just had my tits done you liked him
those seem like lovely tits what him
doesn't give a bit about my tits
well darn him but mrs. Cleary this is
pretty sudden you've been playing cat
and mouse with me ever since you came
here mrs. Cleary I don't come again
okay cat call me okay okay kitty cat
this feels borderline inappropriate
Fiona what I said feel them her mrs.
Cleary I'm sorry kitty cat are you out
your mind I'm not letting you out of
this room I tell you feel so I think the
thing that's really important to note
here is that there is a power dynamic
she is in a position of power it is her
home he wants to make a good impression
and she's put him in a position where if
he gets up and walks out he could be
insulting her and he might make him feel
like the easier thing to do would just
be to acquiesce and do what she's asking
him to do as opposed to make a big scene
and leave her hanging it's probably not
gonna change the legality of it I still
don't see a prosecutor filing charges
based on this conduct I could
potentially see a civil case coming out
of this because it is some form of
harassment but it's unlikely that this
would bring criminal charges
it's already difficult to prove
allegations of sexual assault when there
is a woman victim and in circumstances
when the victim is a male it makes it
even more challenging especially where
the perpetrator is a female the next
clip is from Twilight forks is growing
on me could a guy have anything to do
with that yeah tell me everything what
is indie talk to you later
come on we gotta talk boys are you being
safe did you get in here no window do
you do that a lot oh just a past couple
of months I like watching you sleep it's
um it's kind of fascinating to me um I
just want to try one thing you stay very
still oh my god
don't move in cases that I've come
across where a guy thinks he's being
romantic but the girl doesn't realize
that's what he's doing we call that
stalking and there's nothing romantic
about it you can't just go into a girl's
house and sneak into her room to watch
her sleep over the last couple of months
no that's illegal just the fact that she
was present in the house when he
trespassed it's it's an aggravated
misdemeanor it's called an aggravated
trespass unless he had the intent to do
some sort of felonious act inside the
house commit a felony inside the house
then it would be a residential burglary
and the penalty would be state prison
and a strike
what's important to note in these films
is that there are no consequences for
the perpetrators actions in fact they
don't even really see it as something
that is wrong or illegal this is just a
subplot of the film and that's changing
that's something that I'm hopeful going
forward in films filmmakers are more
careful about what kind of messages
they're sending to young girls and young
boys about what is appropriate behavior
the biggest thing about the me to
movement is that it's bringing forth a
lot of consequences for actions that
previously probably would not have even
been reported and really what we want is
for the media in films to reflect that
to not glorify these actions that
unfortunately victimized a lot of women
and men across the country
[Music]